it has been a terrific start for the
Dallas Cowboys three-and-oh dak has
missed few passes and we all know what
the defense has looked like in a man
who's part of that terrific Dallas
defense and few people have a story to
root for and a person that you should
root for in the NFL quite like this man
Jaylon Smith here on the Rich Eisen show
once again how are you Jalen man I am
doing wonderful enjoying my outfit I bet
you are and but I appreciate you taking
your time and you're off day uh to call
in here because I just wanted to check
in with you your team's three-and-oh and
from what I heard
back in August there is less pie now
because you took your slice Jalen right
black man yeah I bet I bet so what was
it like for you for those who don't know
maybe your story your knee blew up on a
fiesta bowl turf and so did supposedly
your top five prospects of being drafted
the Cowboys took you anyway you balled
out and got this contract that you
deserve what was it like to put your
Jaylon Smith on the dotted line that day
honestly man been playing this game
since I was seven years old and always
dreamt of you know we always dreamed was
a big deal so for me it's just about
embracing it you know I understand and
you know that I'll be able to play for
for America's team you know on a
longevity standpoint so let it buying
that you know this in groups to build
some generation of wealth man but I love
the game of football and I'm just happy
to be able to play the game I love well
what would that kid who was rehabbing
the torn ACL and MCL what would that kid
have thought about this contract man
just making the best you know business
decision you know for yourself you know
for me I've been through a lot you know
it's going to be a top five pick before
my injury and you know was able to you
know still slip into the second round
third pick of the second round and for
me it's just all about patience man so
the hattis have
consumers is really just a blessing but
you know the Cowboys were focused on
winning of course you are and you've won
your now three and OH
how come this year has been so different
do you think then a couple of years that
you've had there in Dallas the the
energy the attention to detail we we
haven't hit our peak at all but no we're
striving to be great and for us it was
just about being together when you say
you haven't hit your peak at all I mean
it's hard to point out how you yeah I'm
not saying that you can't get any better
but it looks pretty super to me Jalen
what do you mean by you you haven't hit
your peak yet we're just laser being
focused man on winning each each game
and taking it week by week taken a day
one day in our preparation you know
that's that's the biggest thing we we
play to our standards you know we're not
focused on any opponent it's the cowboy
standard that we've set for ourselves
and no matter we win or lose if we're
not hitting that standard it's going to
be a problem well who's the one setting
the standard Jalen it's a collective
effort between the between the players
and the coaches okay so walk me through
who the players are leading this from I
mean every player on the team has to be
accountable to it but you know from a
leadership group standpoint you know
captain is on down you know regardless
of our five six captains we have we have
a tremendous amount of leaders in
leadership on the team so you know this
we're able to remove our ego and focus
on each task at hand
Jaylon Smith Cowboys linebacker here on
the Rich Eisen show dak is doing this
without a long-term contract and we've
seen how many players wilt under that or
get distracted by it he seems to just
not even
haier a single lick Jalen what does it
like to be around him man he's a baller
he's the guy that you love and
appreciate and one thing we all know
he's gonna get his money well he keeps
on saying that there it seems the to me
that he thinks that the pie is a little
deeper so when you say I want to delve a
little bit more into your talks with
Jerry here because I had DeMarcus I had
DeMarcus Ware on the show and I asked
him what it was like to negotiate with
Jerry and he said when it was time to
sign he brought DeMarcus into his office
and lit a candle and had a conversation
with him did that happen with you to
something like that you know my
conversations were more with Stephen
okay
but Jerry kind of put the exclamation
point on it man how do you do that can
you walk me through that a little bit I
mean just both both parties we had an
understanding that you know it wasn't
rocket science and we wanted to make it
happen you know fairly quickly you know
we both understood that you know I
wanted to be a cowboy for life and they
wanted me here you know recognize my
value and what I can bring to the table
and then just what I represent
you know as far as off the field just
being a a true match so for us it was
just it was about getting the numbers
right you know obviously they have a lot
of people to get done you know still
still to this day so you know Cooper for
me I recognize you know what it was
gonna take to be you know playing for
America's team and I'm just thankful
with what God has blessed me so but he
did not suit up because again DeMarcus
said he would suit up bring you into the
office light a candle that I'd like a
Cowboys logo on it and have a
heart-to-heart with you that did not
happen with you or did No ours was more
so like in the in the locker room before
one of the preseason games
because it's having a little
heart-to-heart this thing we wanted to
make it happen
well that's great and it did happen for
you and now you know your teammates that
you're with Robert quince sack dance has
gotten a little bit of attention Jalen
are you aware that I'm not no tell me
more okay well let the owner himself
Jerry Jones tell you this is today it
was brought up on Jerry Jones's radio
show today Robert Quinn sac dance and
this was his response to it well that's
one of the best I've seen riding that
pony now you know what's fun sometimes
equal do something like that you'll put
a towel on or he'll put a some shorts on
or something and head down through the
middle of the dressing room kind of
spanking himself as he emulates the
riding the horse but and that's before a
game so you can see how what of a city
is on and off the field to the Dallas
Cowboys what do you think Jalen oh okay
and it fires up your team he does that
and fires everybody up I'm not saying
anything else about he is a character
huh and the fact that he signed what did
that mean for you because so many people
were thinking that it could be a
distraction that he wasn't there when he
signed what did that mean for the locker
room Jalen we all knew that he would he
would be there week one you honor me and
it's business this type of stuff
happened you know so uh we knew what was
gonna get done and have to be able to
play with my brother for the years to
come he is just as good as it gets but
DAC really seems to have taken it to a
new level Jalen I'll be honest with you
I could not be more impressed with the
way he's playing and I'm wondering what
do you do you watch it I know obviously
you've got stuff to prepare for when you
are you are playing but you've got an
amazing television set that Jerry Jones
has put above the field and you're your
home stadium do you sit there and just
take it in
I mean God
no the disguise alignment and that's
that's really odd one thing you know
about you know daggers he's gonna give
it all he's got he's gonna will himself
and that's why he's our quarterback man
all right in the few minutes that I have
left with you Jalen you've never played
in the Superdome before or others have
this is going to be in a very intense
setting it's his loudest Stadium as I've
been in and that includes Arrowhead
Seattle's a great one obviously there
are so many intense places but the
Superdome is definitely a top-five spot
I wonder what you are being told about
this jump in my entire life I could not
wait and you know we're looking forward
to dominating for us is just a bump
affair we got our Sanders man we got him
with us - why have you been dreaming
about it your whole life
just growing up being a football fan and
you know degrees being us Purdue guy you
know for me I'm from the Hoosier State
yep though I've always watched them
growing up in Newark there's nothing
that nothing like it I've never been in
the water so this would be my first time
hopefully we get some good grub tonight
before today I'm sure you will
it's a great town for that and before I
let you go what's going on with you off
the field Jalen what's going on with
your your charity works and what you do
in the Metroplex area to make your world
better as you always do what are you up
to man I started a minority
entrepreneurship Institute in efforts to
close the economic and educational gap
had a successful first showcase in
Indiana next year we'll be traveling to
Dallas Texas having a showcase here
kind of a short think I provide but it
you know we'll have applicants will
narrow it down to five and have them
present in front of myself and a few
other sharks to award three winners with
over $300,000 so what does
getting a financial funding mentorship
and strategic planning like a citizen
efforts for black brown Latinos to close
that educational and economic gap so are
you a fan of shark tank is that where
this is born out of watching that show
and trying to just replicate it no no
not not uh I'm definitely a fan
hmm and outside of the adventure pitch
type of vibe is just I admired being
able to create a marketplace you know
for impact investors you know that want
to help the efforts in like I said close
in the economic and educational gap
that's really my purpose beyond
athletics you know it's only how we're
gonna be able to succeed as a whole in
this universe is for everyone to have
the right access well if there's
somebody sitting at home listening to
this or driving around listening to this
or sitting at home watching it that
thinks that they they've got a great
idea and that this this can work for
them how can they get in touch how can
they make it happen
man just go to my website Jaylon Smith
comm slash Mei and you can apply now
like I said this is the showcase will be
July 10th at the Omni and first go so
just really looking forward to you know
that the happeneth gonna be a glass
jaelyn thanks for the time really
appreciate you spending party your off
day with me congrats on the on on
getting the pie and Anna three no start
will chat down the line hopefully you
gotta that's Jaylon Smith Cowboys
linebacker for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app